I should not have been driving that's
all I know why not because I was
inicated okay where were you
drinking honestly I don't even know I
was drinking at bars and I was just like
yeah I'll just drive home and my ex he
was a real piece of shit controlling
asshole so it's was like fuck it
whatever
um
okay
morning
okay is that your place over there or no
I just driving by oh oh you're just
driving by okay car in the ditch and
like whoa I better out so appreciate you
stopping yeah so no unless you saw it
okay no you're good I appreciate you
stopping making sure she's okay hello
you
okay I'm fine I just feel really
embarrassed oh that's fine that's fine I
just main thing is is you're okay you
don't do you want somebody to come look
at you to make sure um okay okay um what
happened
honestly it was
like mixed
up I don't really exactly
remember okay should not have been
driving that's all I know why not
because I was in
okay where were you
drinking honestly I don't even know I
was drinking at bars and I was just like
fuck yeah I'll just drive home and my ex
he was a real piece of shit controlling
asshole so I was like fuck it
whatever um okay it's not
okay do you
remember do you remember which way you
were coming from can I just go to St
Mary's St Mary's what's in St you're a
long ways from St Mary's oh shit I just
know a lot of people from St Mary's a
lot of family well we'll get we'll get
to that in in a little bit um were you
the only one in the car you were you
were driving okay um have you been
drinking since you wrecked or anything
like that no okay um I wrecked it and I
was like okay so which which way were
you coming from where were you trying to
go
to you coming from that way I think so
yeah you think so you don't quite
remember okay I don't I don't quite
remember step po I just do you have your
driver's license with
you can you call the county road
department uh the road's partially
blocked by a guard rail and the next
rotational toe I'm so sorry that's
okay Jesus Christ how much did you drink
do you
think
um more than the legal a forma green
jeda okay you feel pretty
drunk no but my car won't start
so yeah it's going to have to get towed
unfortunately um
did you did you fall asleep or are you
just too too drunk to be driving you
think it
just was
stupid
I'm cuz I can I can tell youve been
drinking quite a lot I can smell it a
lot your speech is pretty bad so okay
I'm not going to lie about
that you're exactly right I just I just
don't want want to be honest about it
because that's a lot of shit to right
the intersection at be cut off road the
stop signs down in the guard rails out
in the
road okay so I got a question for you
since I know you've been drinking you've
admitted it to me do you am I okay to
drive safe no okay and here's what I'd
like to ask you is if if you would be
willing to perform voluntary field
sobriety tests it will fail all right
we're going to get back to this body cam
in a sec but I want to take a minute to
talk about something else that happens
all the time workplace injuries if you
get hurt at your job whether it's a slip
and fall a mechanical failure negligence
of your co-workers something hits you
you're going to need a trusted law firm
in your corner enter ponle hockey
geordano a firm that is a heavyweight in
the industry that wins all different
kinds of injury cases yes workplace but
also accidents Social Security
Disability injuries they have a track
record of recovering over one billion
dollars for their clients and they have
won over a 100,000 cases they have 250
years of combined experience how amazing
is that so you can check out ponle
hockey Giordano at ponle hockey.com
LC bodycam or you can pick up the phone
and call them at 833 669 4043 all right
let's get back to the body cam why would
you fail because I've drank too much
okay and I'm going to be honest with you
about I and I I I appreciate that not
everybody is nearly as honest as you
okay so here's the deal you can still do
the tests I can base my observations on
what I
see okay that's a it's a yes or no
question so it's up to
you okay okay why don't you set your
purse and stuff on my car I'm going to
get your information down real quick and
then I'll be right back with you okay Y
come over here for
me shit just go and stand like right
here
so what I want you to do right now is
just stand with your feet together hands
down to your side okay so have you had
anything to drink since since you wreck
no NOP okay are you on any medications
or anything like that yes okay what are
you on
um I don't anything that prevents you
from walking or standing or anything
like that okay no um do you have a limp
or anything is your back okay legs okay
all that stuff okay it's all good gotcha
okay so the first thing I'm going going
to do is I'm going to check your eyes
okay so what I need you to do is keep
your hands down at your
side fuck I'm so sorry that's okay can
you see the tip of my my pen here okay
okay don't move your head just follow
with your eyes and your eyes only okay
okay
I want to go home I know I don't want
can you keep following it yeah okay I
don't like this
feeling what feeling is that being in
the middle of nowhere with uh people I
don't know okay I I promise you you're
safe hey can you can you keep following
this yes okay okay
okay keep your head straight at me okay
mhm all
right
okay can you still see it there you go
all right we're we're getting
close
almost done with this
one I failed 100% And that's all right
all right just keep following I'm not
done yet
though okay so the next test is called
the walk and turn test so
what I'm going to have you do um is go
ahead if I can get this thing there we
go okay so what I want you to do right
now is imagine a straight line right in
front of you okay I want you to put your
left foot on that imaginary straight
line put your right foot in front of it
keep your hands down at your side don't
do anything else until I tell you to
okay can you do that you cannot do that
okay I'm we'll try this I'm intoxicated
I will admit it okay do you want to do
you want to S do do the test you want to
try the test sure I'll fail but sure so
the best you can try to stay in that
position when I tell you to begin I'm
going to have you take a series of nine
Heel To Toe steps counting each step out
loud want you to keep your hands down to
your side look down at your feet okay
it's going to look just like this I'm
only going to take three you're going to
take nine but it's going to look just
like this okay one two three and so on
so simple until you reach your ninth
step so hard okay when you reach your
ninth step step out with your back foot
take a series of small steps until you
reach the direction you came
from count e step out loud five six 7 8
10 1 two three
four five six
seven eight N9 10 okay next test is a
one leg stand so I have you do same
thing feet together hands down to your
side just like this okay when I tell you
to I'm going to have a raise a foot of
your choice approximately 6 in off the
ground
keep okay I tell you what you don't have
to do that one it's horrible so the last
one is a portable breath test it's not
in Li of the evidentiary breath test
okay when's the last time you had
something to drink
uh I'll probably say about 12:30 a.m.
okay do you want to take a uh voluntary
portable breath test yeah okay can you
spit your gum out for
me okay so when I tell you
to I'm probably going to fail and that's
fine okay but when I tell you to I'll
just have you seal your lips around this
straw and blow like your blown into a
balloon okay I'll coach you through
it okay take a deep breath seal your
lips around the
straw okay blow harder harder harder
harder there you go go go go go go go go
go go okay if you had to guess how high
do you think you are
um
78.9 78.9 that's that's a random number
I'll take it
okay you right now you're at 237 okay
the legal limit is a is a 08 mhm so
you're about three times out okay so you
are under arrest for DUI
okay so walk to the front of my car okay
face the front of my car put your hands
right here on the small your back
okay there you go just relax go ahead
and stand up straight up I don't want to
hurt
your I did this
so you do have the right to remain
silent WR to an
attorney okay do you have anything on
you that I need to know about I got to
search you okay just uh stay face in my
car go ahead and separate your feet okay
no I
don't
okay
okay I'm just going to use the back of
my hand okay no you're good you're
good okay let's go around this way
here I'm really s we're going to keep
going I just don't want to walk you near
the
ditch you're
fine okay watch your step okay okay
all right um I'm going to grab your
purse is there anything where's your
insurance in your car do you know it's
in my wallet in your wallet okay I'll
bring that over to you
okay okay I'm going to read your rights
again okay okay we'll go with that for
now I'm going to grab your purse and
stuff off your car and I'm going to have
some paperwork to do before we get out
of here okay
okay all right go and step on out you
doing
okay oh you okay I'm good all right just
face the wall
here I don't have my glasses on I don't
know which are oh you're you're okay can
you see okay without them yes okay I
just need to know what chair you need to
go through I know I'm going to take
these off for a second
so if you need to use a restroom Now's
the Time
okay cuz after that it's going to be
probably well half hour okay okay are
you okay for a half hour or do you need
to
go okay so have a seat in this fancy
chair right here oh cow I
know and just so you know I I am still
recording okay I know
I got to tell you I got to tell you
about 100
times okay
sir so what I'm going to do now and this
is no offense to you I do it the same
with everybody is I going to put you
back in your handcuffs because for a
while I can't let you touch your mouth
or put your hands near your mouth and
it's a lot harder than you think so I
just go and stand up for a
sec there we
go people do it out of habit and then we
got to start everything over and it's a
mess okay go and have a seat
again okay did you work
today no hey I got to I could just ask
you're good I have this weekend off
actually so awesome that's why you're
partying it up so
hard um how many hours of sleep did you
get last night not very
much um I definitely wanted to party it
up yes um also or let me ask you this
did you sleep last
night no okay I'm going to be honest
with you no okay were you driving the
vehicle yes is there anything
mechanically wrong with the
vehicle not that I know no okay um have
you been injured or involved in any
collisions in the past 24 hours
no uh have you had any alcohol to drink
since being stopped or since your
Collision
no what time did you uh crash your
car the call was about like 900 a.m.
right
so
probably 8:30 a.m. okay is somewhere in
there
okay um let's see where were you going
before you before you the Collision I
was trying to
get
um I was trying to get to a friend's
house okay what what city or where do
you know where that's
at it's in the the St Mary's region okay
nothing different that's a ways away
oh
sorry uh without looking what time do
you think it
is honestly probably
10:23 p.m. a.m. 10:23 a.m. yeah I have
no idea okay I don't have a watch I have
no sense of
time uh what street or Highway were you
W and if you don't know you don't know I
don't know but I just know it's like one
of the main
highways because um they stop and do you
know what direction of travel you were
going uh
forward so forward
okay sorry is that your answer no okay
what direction of travel do you think
you going and if you don't no you don't
know
um let's go forward with like the extra
added this to
it all right uh where did you start
driving from
same
and oops uh what time did you start
driving I have no idea
okay I'm going to be Hest I'm
sorry what day of the week is it now it
is
Saturday and what city and county are
you in
now
it's uh I know it's Whitman County right
mhm okay and I'm yep that's it okay
sorry that's okay Whitman county
um this uh what's the date
today
[Music]
21 and have you been drinking alcoholic
beverages in the last 24 hours sure
yes um what have you been
drinking a little bit of
everything
okay um how
much I want to think I did not drink
more than
7.0% but also at the same time like I
cannot be responsible enough to be like
I didn't do that okay uh when did you
start
drinking 1: a.m. I guess
okay um who have you been drinking
with um recently just by myself actually
um really
depressing
okay and where were you
drinking my
car and what time was your last
drink
what time is the it's almost
9:00 I guess my last drink was before
you guys showed up at the crimine well
not criming but like you know okay you
have an idea of what time that would
have
been and again if you don't know you
don't know I don't know but I can guess
like
A45
okay this is really
hard um almost done with all these
questions uh you good do you believe
your ability to drive was affected by
your alcohol and or drug
usage a little bit yeah
okay this is a lot different have you
been arrested for DUI before no
okay okay we got about another minute
then we can start this whole thing here
and then we'll be done no worries you're
good and you said this is a current
address right
everything on there is um accurate
except for the apartment part uh they
just did not have that on uh what's your
apartment
number
wow I'm following My Father's Footsteps
and that's a real
incredible well it's only one
night right one mistake maybe it's a big
mistake but oh well it's only one one
mistake that's
true thank
you can I have these UNC uh in about
maybe less than 10 minutes we're getting
close okay it just it's really
uncomfortable
um when I tell you to I'm going to have
you take a deep breath just kind of like
we did out by your car but for this one
you're going to have to seal your lips
about halfway up and you're going to
have to blow for at least about 10
seconds okay okay so super deep
breath seal your lips around and I'll
coat you through it
okay okay keep going keep going keep
going keep going keep going go go go go
go go go go go go
go keep going okay good that's
good we'll do that one more time in
about 3 minutes okay this
isfort I know we got about 3 minutes and
then I'll get those off as soon as I can
okay any other tests this is it oh so I
failed we don't know that yet I def no I
have a
suspicion a su suspicion but we don't
know yet
absolutely
suspicion this is reallyy
[Music]
painful okay one more
time just like the first time deep deep
breaths seal your lips around the
tube okay keep going keep going keep
going keep going keep going go go go go
go go go
okay that's good all
right soon as this tells me I can take
it off I will and then we'll get your uh
handcuffs off
okay fair enough fair
enough all right let's get those off go
and stand up actually I think I can do
it right here I can't stand up
okay
[Music]
there we
go all right what's the magic number
going to
be oh
shit I don't know why ask
me magic number H is there like
uh
like cut
off it'll go to the
Moon
um
2.88 all right we'll
see
it's got to print out first what are
youing where I'm
at fair enough fair
enough
okay here we
go I don't think we need a drem roll for
this one please no uh so here you go
here's your numbers
99201 these are two different results so
you're roughly about at 0.20 okay that's
really
high okay yeah way way too high to be
driving but you knew that and you told
me that so yes let's not go through this
part again
right please
no I don't want to feel like this again
I wouldn't either I already feel like a
failure throughout like every day today
life I don't mean to feel like a fail to
this okay so you're going to get a copy
of that with your stuff that's going to
be you can just leave that there cuz
it's got to go in your box
um you got an Idaho driver's license so
I don't need to do the DOI
hearing I don't think I need to give you
this but this is a request for a dii
hearing through Washington D well but
you have an Idaho driver's license
so um I want to make sure I got
everything I need
Before I Let You Go fair
enough I think we're good
okay so I will
call the jail staff I'll come get
you and then I got to type a report
before we can move forward with you or
they can move forward with
you my call cannot be
completed
incredible hey she's
ready by
is that what you do
yeah
yep do they stay in control for the most
part unless they need to be not in
control pretty much yeah unless they're
cleaning something
or yeah doing rounds or
something oh wait a
minute apparently we have to clean this
now
don't want germs
no could use a
wash
same same with you you need a wash
yeah not here though like at home
preferably at home that's always better
yeah so I'm going to put this stuff in
your property over here let me just make
sure did I miss the keys did you have
the keys in your purse you know what you
sure did that's my bad
the tow truck driver was looking for him
and I told him I didn't have
them okay all set you want me to hang
out n okay miss you do you take this
jumpuit roll these shoes right here you
to go inside the restroom right there
remove everything you have on jewelry
everything and only put these on and
then come back out Stu in that
basket
sure can you give us the magic doors she
needs she needs to go out that way and I
need to go this
way 31
3208 all right I will meet you in report
writing remember how to get there yes
good I don't want you getting lost
now